[Music]
ii ET shows up for officially back at
season 3 season time yes EG was on the
set of unreal season at 3 and wall week
and it's phil show secrets just yet
we did get the cast to weigh in on this
season of The Bachelor I haven't been
watching I've just been a little
overwhelmed yeah and then when you come
home you don't want to watch the show
you're making you go girl you do you I'm
gonna do me okay but still we have to
talk about her in I was waiting to
talked about correct she is Tinky goal
is she not my heart is gold but my
regime is platinum
no no what no wife is dying on her when
he's I literally punch her in the face
it's like she's been plucked straight
out of everlasting and dropped into the
bachelor and that's when we say thank
you we're doing our job right I love it
I think she's incredible I think that
what's interesting is that I think that
um
you know as likable as she is I think
she was clearly there and made it as far
as she did because the producers needed
good TV amazing like bow on bow on I
haven't seen I'll have to watch I'll put
it on my put it on my cue I like to call
it the Corrine show this season it's the
Corrine chef high but this summer it
will be the Rachael Lindsay show as the
31 year old a lawyer from Dallas becomes
the franchise's first ever black
bachelorette describe yourself as the
Bachelorette in one word direct ain't
awesome yeah I think it's fantastic it's
about time and I would like to just have
an ego and say maybe add a little bit to
do with us are you ready to welcome this
serious back he's black and you want him
dating white girls
oh please gonna be making deep dark
nasty love to them to like if we've been
a catalyst for anything if we were a
part of that story fantastic and I hope
she has a really great experience and
finds what she's looking for
I mean it's about damn time is what I
think I think that she's the perfect
choice it's really strange to see just
you know a very whitewashed world in TV
it's very odd because that's not how the
world actually it I don't think that it
was um that her selection was um you
know based strictly upon the color of
her skin I think that she is so nuanced
and has so many you know beautiful
qualities of character or and she's the
eyes she out of all of the girls black
white asian latina whatever I think that
Rachel was was the perfect thing
[Music]
you